how are you good go through back good so
is this album done yeah I just have to
like really get down to what songs are
actually going to be onyx so I know I
like too many you do I'm about two songs
off full of completion what is that like
when you have to kill something it's not
nice not as it might never get hurt
again which is a shame rate really but
I've got just you know I've got like 18
songs I personally think that's too many
yeah so if I can get rid of three or
four that would be the dream that seems
cruel that after all the all the work
everything else that now you're tasked
with axing three for the sake of three
being too many it's very like trivial
for something that is so heartbreaking I
you know I know it is Toph is like some
songs make it for like emotional value
some songs make it Custer great songs
and they're emotional and so I've got to
like I got I produced fully and recorded
for like 20 of the 60 that I wrote yeah
and just kind of Whittle it down from
there so I have to make some like
grueling decisions and recently I was in
New York and I've got my cousin's live
in New York and they're like big pop
fans and I was sending I was going to
send them the album the two of them and
tell them to see if there's a common
denominator right and see what ones they
will get rid of that's my next that's
stuff out there so let's go the other
way then what was the song that you said
this is the one that is absolutely
staying regardless of anything else
there is one there's one it's a ballad
and it will make it for emotional
reasons yeah versus maybe it's I don't
know if it's a best song in the world I
really like the song yeah that's my
opinion
can you say the name of the song no no
okay do that that would be the right
thing to do I know yeah it's just and
there's one in particular that what
won't won't be moved
No shall not be moved what were the
emotional reasons it's it obviously
you're attached to this song yeah you
know you get attached the songs you know
like you write them about certain thing
and then it would be a shame for the
whole song right impressive process to
go along and this song not get hurt
right even if no one knows what it means
sure but you know the rain like I
I still attached to him what do you
people to attach themselves to it do you
are you the type of artist that struggle
with the fact that when you are busted
up heartbreak whatever it is great art
sometimes comes from that it happens a
lot yeah you definitely need life
experiences to write songs there's no
doubt about it it makes it makes your
ideas come quicker it makes you be more
honest yeah
and because otherwise you just coupe up
inside and know nothing ever gets out
and so that's yeah but what about the
line though when you are going through
something right that is emotional to you
is there line we're in the moment you
may want to say everything do you then
have to sort of step away to recalibrate
how far you want to go inside your own
heart no no you could go like it
sometimes it's you don't want to write
that I heard Camila Cabello say actually
recently that she was writing the song
and she wrote a really like grueling
line and then it was like no I can't do
it because it'll hurt the other person's
feelings right you know so the song
could have been a bit more stick the
knife in and turn it but yeah like
taking it out just for you know to save
yeah you worked with a lot of producers
yes some great producers I'd I can't
remember the names of the you work with
the guy who did hello Adele's hello and
Greg Kurstin Gregerson yes and what was
the mandate for that track for ones that
I did with him yeah I mean the Greg is
just like a he's one of few people that
I know that are actually like a musical
genius yeah like I would said he was the
most musical guy I've ever met he can
play every instrument to any level he
also can produce any type of song he's
really diverse yeah and so this time I
was like I just know what what is good
about Greg Karstens music when I listen
to it so I know that I'm just gonna
untrust them I know what he's gonna do
if I give him like a you know give him a
shape and then he can kind of knock it
around a little bit and he can you know
make it whatever way he he wants it but
I have a fair idea of what I said I like
some sound like because that song it is
interesting because you know do you
remember the reaction when Hello came
out which was the meme was everybody
listening to it the first time ball way
yeah
no he he was telling me like the day
didn't even have a chorus for that song
for like six months like it was just
kind of like he's a very like deep
thinker he's never happy with what you
come up with first which is the best
thing you need is a writer if you're
happy with what you came up with first
then you're no good so how quickly do
your feelings change towards things
because you have a little while before
people hear this and do your feelings
change of where you want to then last
minute go in and make changes whether it
be technical lyrical emotional because
you can't touch it after a certain point
I know it just has to sit there no
you're given like a you're basically
like one slice choose it you've
basically a few weeks to get everything
into gear for the label to go and do
their job and get it to the right people
around the world so there's a lot of
like you need to get like all your
mixing done and your mastering and you
know recording and stuff like that and
there has been times where I've gone
back and done little bits and pieces but
it's so it's once the bulk of it's done
all the little tweaking and stuff can be
done from anywhere it's an interesting
world of music right now because there
was a time so that there was a picture
of you and Selena Gomez there was a time
where people would see that picture and
they would say oh my god they're dating
and they'd be disappointed when you're
not now the way the world works is oh my
god they're collaborating I know
honest everybody just wants the
collaborations now yeah people are
fickle Aaron they they don't know
whether they want us today or go on a
song together I think they want you what
assault yeah more yeah no I mean that
would be great the girl she's obviously
talented Garland she's really good
really good friend of mine you a lot of
talented friends and how have you guys
not just are there recordings that we
will never hear of just like you and
some of your friends where you've sat
down somebody hit record on a phone and
you've created something and saying
something that will never see the light
of day no it is you're like you're
friends with these people like you are
you know what any of your friends but
you just you don't think when you're
sitting around you know or if I'm coming
to town or whatever I'm never gonna go
right come on let's go into the studio
let's take full advantage of me being
here it's more let's go for dinner or
let's hang out or whatever so maybe not
ready so much let's go into the studio
but like here Shawn Mendes let's say
yeah let's have a few beers grab a
guitar
and forget about everything yeah that
sort of situation I know but this is the
thing a lot of collaborations don't
happen for this exact reason right I
come to Toronto on once a year maybe
yeah
Sean's not here right he's in China or
something right so he could not be any
further so that's exactly half the
reason why things don't happen right so
I've summed I've summed up a lot of
collaboration so hard because all the
artists are doing different stuff you
know it's right New York was in China
this work the story behind nice to meet
you mm what is it a good night oh yeah
by the sounds of it it sounds like
everything it looks like you know my
head to try and paint a picture when you
go to write a song and I wanted this to
be kind of a fun night out and not over
at all you know because when when I was
writing this album I tried to get all
the feelings that you have after a
breakup you know like the days where
you're sitting there and you're writing
sad ballad songs and yeah feeling sorry
for yourself and I also wanted to write
songs like nice to meet you which is
like let's go into town with all my
mates and just we'll have a bit of fun
and not worry about all the sad stuff
that's there are the things that you do
when you go through a breakup or
whatever so nice to meet you is
basically just about being out and Soho
in London yeah go on a night and then
kind of like bumping into this
particular person and then crossing
paths with them across the night you
know even without can I try in yeah and
that can't be hard for you though well
it is when you're wearing a hat just
kind of like it's almost I'm always
trying to catch you up and they don't
know who you are what do you do at that
point you have a line no just like will
just take your hat off and go no I try
and keep it as I did sometimes sometimes
I've made up jobs really yeah go to job
I usually try and stand next to my
cousin who works in property yeah then
try and learn a bit about his job and
then he if I struggled then he can help
me really and they can you pretend
you're a real estate agent
sometimes yeah yeah yeah that's
incredible yes yeah that's the kind of
and so it's also fun then the minute you
mentioned that you're a singer
everyone starts challenging you on it
sure you know that what have you done
and then you have to dig into what you
do
even like it's a normal songwriter they
have that problem say alright and what
song have you written yeah you know yeah
it's just it's quite frustrating to
listen to so I just try to make up lies
just right and then tell them later let
it all develops
so is this album then perfect for
somebody who would it seems like to me
is it's perfect for somebody who is
maybe going through something like a
breakup but also wants moments to forget
that they're going through something
like a breakup exactly here not can I
use this in a few months when I'm not in
doubt much kind of your face is gonna
come up and it's gonna be you saying
that like you created that's what it
sounds like you were going through in
your head in your heart and other people
will relate because we've all gone
through it no no you do like and I was
just thinking there's like last time it
was more of a heartbreak thing and then
I was just say how do you do heartbreak
in a different way yeah and the first
thing I wrote down was the album title
which you'll hear and then I was just
kind of like then I can like branch off
that if that's my if that's my center
point I can just kind of write different
songs around that and that's the kind of
idea what I was doing was like some
nights you feel like you want to go out
and your friends didn't break the place
and then the other days you're like
pretty sad yeah so basically yeah coming
out of one one direction you guys the
fascinating thing was is I don't know if
any of you really took the easy path
with your solo stop it was almost like
you deliberately set out to try and win
people over again after the massive
success that you had yes both so yeah we
all love that was what was great about
the music that we did was we all had
different tastes of music
me and Harry probably closer didn't
arrested him yeah in terms of like what
we listen to sure we recently went to a
gig together and stuff we've similar
taste in music but yeah we you try and
find your own sound I knew exactly what
mine was from I've known it all my life
if I always lay if I was when I was 10
years old I knew what my oven was going
to sound like really slow and chilled
out and how I would announce myself into
the music world and that's the way it
did this time got a lot touring under my
belt
yeah and know how it feels to be on
stage in front of thousands and kind of
watch them sway for 90 minutes it's not
the best thing to look out yeah so I
just pick up the energy that button show
off the that style of Thurman
yeah you are young talented and rich
tell me right now convince me that
that's not the best life ever
I mean let's throw famous in there as
well all right um yeah I mean it all is
not perfect about that life they've all
got their pros and cons as they as you
get as you could probably say I see
famous what sucks about that
walking around yeah it's getting better
wear a hat I have to wear a hat a lot
yeah
that side of it is just that's the only
side that I don't really like and do you
have time to spend your money no not
really
no I'm also no I'm also not really that
way inclined anyway to be honest kind of
like I was brought up a certain way yeah
I know how to do things I was kind of
quite like independent as a kid anyway
so I knew what I needed to do I don't
spend stupid money and it's a long life
yeah and yeah are you like you're like
somebody has like a fight like people in
your family that are telling you to be
financially like you advice like we all
did when we were young yeah no my dad's
all over that stuff kind of like nowhere
to put it
yeah I mean I've been doing it for long
enough now as well there I know I know
what I know what I'm up to
yeah and obviously there's a lot of
foolish people out there too but what's
that's up to them lots